Iranian forces attacked the American
Embassy in Iraq anti-semitic attacks
become commonplace in New York City and
Democrats continue to push impeachment
happy new year i'm ben shapiro this is
the ben shapiro show the ben shapiro
show is sponsored by expressvpn protect
your online privacy today and expressive
VPN comms life and great thing to do in
New Year well happy New Year to y'all
hope that you had a wonderful vacation
if you were able to take a vacation I
hope that you had a wonderful Christmas
great Hanukkah Happy New Year and we're
back and you know what that means it's
time for an international emergency so
over in Iraq things have been degrading
integrating fairly quickly that is
because the government of Iraq has
always been torn between these sectarian
divides Sunni and Shia this has been
true for a very long time in the
aftermath of Saddam Hussein's fall and
the disbanding of the Iraqi military
sectarian violence obviously started to
take root in Iraq in recent years there
was an attempt by the United States to
help bring together a government that
would both fight off Isis and that would
resist Iran that has proved to be harder
than expected simply because Iran's
influence in the region has tremendously
tremendously grown and that is in large
part thanks to the fact that the Obama
administration decided to basically make
room for the Iranians and now you're
saying all these members of the media
all these members of the left who are
suggesting that it's president Trump's
fault that Iranian terrorists attempted
to storm the US Embassy over the last
three or four days and they're trying to
suggest that this is because of Trump's
harsh policy on Iran no this is because
when you appease a power like Iran their
power grows and they are able to stage
events like this one and this is two
very different views of foreign policy
and it's something that we ought to take
note of because there is this tendency
inside the right to be isolationist as
well and these views of foreign policy
one suggest that the role of the United
States in the world should be basically
we stay within our own borders we wait
to be hit if we are hit then we lash out
in sort of quick fashion and then we
retreat back inside our own borders and
that the outside world has nothing to do
with us and this was America's foreign
policy for large swathes of time up
until the beginning of the 20th century
essentially and then there's the other
view which is that the world has become
a very very small place and what that
means is that when things happen abroad
eventually they are going to end up as
being threats to the United States and
so one of the goals of
military one of the goals of American
foreign policy is to quash threats
before they occur it's to make sure that
we can minimize the possibility of risk
growing and so to take an example there
are two views that were prevalent in the
United States in the 1930s in the lead
up to World War two and this is none of
this as meant to suggest that we're
about to go to war with Iran which we
are not okay but there were two views in
the 1930s in the lead-up to World War
two view number one was the old sort of
isolationist view and this was
predominant in the United States it was
the view of the of the Republican Party
it was the view of populist like father
Coughlin it was the view of many people
who suggested that the United States
basically had no role in the world if
there was chaos over in Europe well that
was that was the Europe problem if there
was chaos over between Japan and China
that was really Japan and China problem
it wasn't really a u.s. problem and then
that problem started to arrive on
America's front doorstep and back
doorstep as it turns out and then Pearl
Harbor happens now what what's
interesting about the reaction of the
United States to Pearl Harbor is that we
immediately got our back up and we
recognized that our role in the world
had to change because the fact is this
the United States pretty easily could
have come to some sort of accommodation
with the Japanese that would have
allowed them to maximize their regional
power even after Pearl Harbor in fact
it's possible that's what the Japanese
government thought was going to happen
is that the United States was not going
to go to full-scale war with Japan even
after Pearl Harbor because isolationist
sentiment was so strong and so they felt
like okay well if we hit them then maybe
they'll back off okay that's not what
happened the United States got its
backup and instead the United States
ends up defeating Japan and occupying
Japan for the next 80 years the United
States does the same thing with regard
to Germany right the America America's
role in the world fundamentally changes
because we recognize after World War two
that there is no more of this we can
retreat within our own borders and
everybody will leave us alone well that
has only become worse over time and
every so often reminds it of this and
9/11 we were reminded that we can leave
the Middle East alone we can basically
have a light footprint in the Middle
East we can say that that region of the
world has not much to do with us and
that will not stop terrorists from
hating us and wanting to attack us and
wanting to kill American citizens and
again there are two ways of viewing
America's military response to events
like this one is that in the aftermath
of Pearl Harbor which killed on the
order of 2,000 Americans that in the
aftermath of Pearl Harbor America then
entered a war in which 200,000 American
were killed right in in World War two
was that a disproportionate response in
some ways I think there are some
isolationist could argue yes pap you can
infer egg for example has sort of argued
yes okay the same thing has happened in
the aftermath of 9/11 there's the
argument that was made that they yes
they killed 3,000 of our citizens but
then we've been involved in wars that
have killed more American troops than
that more American troops have died in
those wars but this fundamentally miss
states the role of the American military
and the role of America in the world and
that is the American military people
sign up it's it particularly now it's a
volunteer military these are heroes who
are signing up to defend America's
freedom they're not signing up in order
to be paid to sit at a base in Georgia
right that is not why they sign up and
to treat them as children to treat our
soldiers as the left likes to do as sort
of pawns in political games where
anytime somebody says we need to use
troops to defend our embassy in Baghdad
for example then the left says well how
many troops are you willing to put a
risk listen that's a fine question but
it's not a fine question if you do it
every single time we talked about using
military force in defense of American
assets abroad so we have to decide is
what we want America's role in the world
to be and also we have to be realistic
about the fact that if America retreats
from certain areas of the world other
forces take over if Iran takes over Iraq
if Iran takes over Syria if Iran takes
over Lebanon Iran takes over Yemen that
has significant ramifications for
America's foreign policy not just in
terms of the economy and shutting down
the Straits of Hormuz but in in terms of
actual security policy the fact is the
Iranian government is the chief sponsor
of worldwide terror on planet Earth
right now if the Iranians take over the
region that maximizes Russian aggression
Russian power which has ramifications
for Europe if the Chinese are working
with the Russians and with the Iranians
then it maximizes Chinese power at the
expense of American power in the world
now economics is not a zero-sum game but
foreign policy to a certain extent is in
fact a zero-sum game and when America
pulls back it is not that this becomes a
vacuum it is that that vacuum is very
quickly filled so there gonna be people
who today tomorrow as we come back into
the new year argue that all of this is
happening in Iraq because the United
States ought to take a more isolationist
view toward the world that all this has
happened with regard to China in Russian
if we just leave them alone they'll
leave us alone but that is not the
reality the reality is that if we leave
all this stuff alone all we are doing is
in Boldin
America's enemies to grow stronger and
then when conflict does occur we are
facing down a much stronger enemy right
now one of the things that is occurring
from from sort of the old Obama acolytes
they're saying well if we had just left
Iran alone if we just continued to pay
off Iran
well then Iran wouldn't be as violent
right now with America now first of all
that's not true I mean Iran is
responsible for the deaths of literally
thousands of American service people in
Iraq and so the Iranians have not been
our friend for quite a while going all
the way back to the mullahs in 1979 but
there's this case that's being made by
the Obama contingent that if we just
paid them off everything would have been
fine and it's Trump's harsh stand
against the Iranians that is causing
them to get violent okay go back to 1940
and the in the Munich Accords and think
to yourself or 1939 in the Munich
Accords 38 38 the Munich Accords and
think to yourself what did what would
have happened if after the Munich
Accords but before Hitler violates the
Munich Accords Churchill was elected and
then Churchill's takes a very strong
stand and then Hitler starts attacking
the countries surrounding him isn't it
true that people on the Left would then
have blamed Churchill and his strong
stand against the Germans for provoking
appeasement looks good until the point
at which the appeaser is stepped on the
problem is if people foresee that and
they let somebody who's no longer going
to appease it's easy for people on the
left and for isolationists to to suggest
that it's the intransigence of
strong-willed people standing up against
evil that is the cause of the evil being
evil and that's never true the Iranian
government has been evil for 40 years
the the German government was evil
before Churchill was elected and before
Churchill took over and the governor and
the Chamberlain government collapsed you
evil doesn't need an excuse to be evil
can we'll get into what's actually
occurring here and why President Trump
is doing the right thing in Iran at what
foreign policy ought to look like there
nobody is calling for over at war I will
said it's 1000 times today
no one wants war with Iran no one wants
in open conflict with Iran there are
things we can do short of that open
conflict to stop them from pursuing this
aggressive policy in the region and
putting more Americans at risk and
creating a stronger Iran to be used
against their own citizens and more
importantly against America's other
allies around the Middle East and
America herself we'll get to that in
just one second first let us talk about
something that you need going into the
new year
okay the thing you need going in you
need to be comfortable down below
yeah let's face it we're going into the
new year I know it's the most depressing
day of the year right it's the day after
New Year you got all your resolutions in
order and you know you're gonna fail but
one thing is for certain you need to be
comfortable where it counts and this is
why you require Tommy John Tommy John
obsesses over every little detail and
stitch by using proprietary fabrics that
perform like nothing you have ever worn
before
as a result Tommy John's men's and
women's underwear sport a no wedgie
guarantee comfortable stay put waist
bands and a range of fabrics that are
luxuriously soft feather-light moisture
wicking breathable and designed to move
with you not against you that means no
bunching and no riding up Tommy John is
so confident in their underwear that if
you don't love your first pair and get a
full refund with their best pair you'll
ever wear or it's free guarantee if you
prefer to shop in stores you can find
them in over 1,200 retail locations
across the country including Nordstrom
stores nationwide Tommy John no
adjustment needed once you go to Tommy
John you're never going back I mean
these underwear are just phenomenal that
would make female products also they're
just great my wife loves them hurry -
Tommy John calm /ban for 20% off your
first order great way to start the new
year Tommy John calm /ban for 20% off
that's Tommy John calm /ban go check
them out right now okay so here is the
actual latest from what is happening
over in Baghdad is according to the New
York Times as of last night after a
second day of tense protests at the
American Embassy in Baghdad thousands of
pro-iranian demonstrators dispersed on
Wednesday demonstrators is code for many
of these people are terrorists that
literally a terrorist group called
Hezbollah which has outlets this is sort
of the Iraqi outlet there's the Iraqi
outlet of Hezbollah it's sponsored by
the Iranian hoods force which is a wing
of their Revolutionary Guard Hezbollah
has thousands of rockets pointed at
Israel and Lebanon Hezbollah has a
significant role in the conflict in
Syria Hezbollah is one of the worst
terrorist groups on the planet it is
labeled as such by the American State
Department and by an increasing number
of European countries and if the
Europeans label some somebody it from
the from the Middle East a terrorist
then it's a fairly good shot that
international terrorist group hey after
a second they have tense protests at the
American Embassy in Baghdad thousands of
pro-iranian demonstrators dispersed on
Wednesday ending a siege that had
trapped American diplomats in the
embassy compound overnight winding down
a potentially explosive crisis for the
Trump administration the demonstrators
had swarmed outside the embassy chanting
to America in your attempts by the way
originally turned these people mourners
which shows you where their heads are at
what exactly were they supposedly
mourning they were mourning the fact
that the United States had attacked
Hezbollah encampments in Syria and Iraq
because these are places from which
Hezbollah fighters have been going out
and trying to kill Americans and
American allies in contrast to Tuesday
when some demonstrators forced their way
into the compound and said some of the
outbuildings on fire they're not
demonstrators demonstrators don't break
into embassies and set things on fire
those are called terrorists the crowd on
Wednesday was smaller no protesters
breached the compounds gates women's
demonstrators largely members of
iranian-backed militias angered by
deadly American airstrikes over the
weekend I do love it when they suggest
that they are angered by deadly American
airstrikes you know until then there
were nice guys but then it was that the
United States attacks on terror bases
and then they were like oh man I'm so
pissed off until this I was just like
you're nice normal terrorist I wasn't
gonna let go burn an embassy or
something but now that you killed my
terrorist friends now I'm like a super
really giant angry terrorist and I'm
gonna go burn crap alternatively these
were terrorists who were looking for an
excuse to go and do something bad and so
they stormed the the embassy the outer
walls of the embassy and this force
American inside the embassy the the the
American military to fire tear gas into
the crowd when the demonstrators reached
the roof of the burned reception
building on Wednesday American security
forces including marine reinforcements
sent by the Pentagon the day before fire
tear gas to drive them back and you can
see from the video I mean these are
people who are arriving with battering
rams and weapons we're all the females I
mean if these if these are demonstrators
have you seen a single female why is it
that these are all military aged males
were carrying Hezbollah flags could it
be that they are actually terrorists and
so sick of the media covering for
terrorists and pretending they're just
demonstrators that's insane the full
withdrawal came after leaders of the
iranian-backed militias who had
organized the demonstration called on
the crowd to leave and most gradually
drifted away on foot or drove off in
trucks the leaders later announced that
their agreements withdrawal was
conditioned on a commitment from Iraq's
Prime Minister Aldo Abdul Mahdi to Peru
to move ahead with legislation to force
American troops to withdraw from Iraq
Samadhi
had been protested by thousands of Iraqi
citizens who said that he's in thrall to
the Iranians
now Mahdi's caught between a couple
between a rock and a hard place
basically a large part of
country ashiya a huge percentage of the
parliament is Shia many members of the
government are Shia many of them are in
thrall to Iran meanwhile he has a vast
Sunni population as well the Shia want
the Americans to leave so that Iran can
help overrun Iraq
the Sunnis want the Americans to stay so
that America can help protect them
against the Iranians now if you're
American you're going what role do we
have in all of this well the role is to
basically keep the peace and the reason
you need to keep the peace is because if
the Iranians overrun Iraq then they now
run all territory between Afghanistan
and the and the coast of the
Mediterranean Sea and they they now run
everything basically ranging all the way
as far east as parts of Afghanistan and
then all the way as far west as Lebanon
and as far south as Yemen and by the way
working in coordination with the
Russians and the Chinese so if you worry
about America's place in the world about
our foreign policy but the possibility
of a major war breaking out here's the
thing war breaks out for a variety of
reasons but one of those reasons is when
your enemies think they are stronger
than you and they take advantage of that
strength right now America's enemies
recognize that America does not want to
go to war with anybody and so they're
pushing at the borders right they're
pushing this is what Putin has been
doing he did it in Crimea he did it in
Georgia he's been pushing consistently
the Iranians are pushing consistently
the Chinese are pushing consistency it
consistently they're basically using the
old Stalinist tactic of push where it's
mush right and then and you push until
until the much stops basically well the
question is when is America's back going
to get up with all of this President
Trump is saying right now like this this
bleep ends right now Iran's ability to
deploy militias to blockade American
diplomats inside the embassy for most of
two days made clear how much power they
wield within the Iraqi government
according to the American government the
Iraqi government didn't do enough at the
very beginning to defend America's
embassy in Iraq that sovereign American
territory according to the New York
Times despite a 16 year American effort
to establish a government friendlier to
Western interests at a cost of more than
one trillion dollars and 5,000 American
lives Iraq's leaders lined up in
opposition's the American airstrikes and
its security forces allowed the militias
to reach the American diplomatic
compound okay that is not because the
government is anti-american it's because
the government is in thrall to the
Iranians and that is because America has
lessened its footprint in Iraq and so if
you're in Iraq and you are betting on
the future of the country who do you
think has
staying power the Iranians were the
Americans if America really showed
listen we're not going anywhere we're
gonna stay here until this thing is
locked down we're at least gonna provide
you the help you need until this thing
is locked down against Iran then the
Iraqi government would probably be a lot
more forthcoming in terms of the
resources they provide to the American
government that's what the American
government is staying is saying by the
way it is also true that consistent
American unwillingness to confront the
Iranian aggression over the past year
and a half right the Iranians firing on
ships in the Straits of Hormuz the
Iranians shooting down an American drone
America basically doing very little
except passing a few sanctions the
Iranians are pushing where do they think
that it's much
well the moosh has now ended well get to
president Trump's response to all this
which is the correct response the media
know it's the correct response which is
why they are frustrated by it we'll get
to all of that in just one second first
let us talk about making your employment
better don't let what happened to me
happen to you I'm just kidding
mostly but let's say that you had a
producer for your show and this producer
was like key to the show and let's say
it was your very first day back your
very first day back in a brand-new year
one of the most important days of the
year and let's say that this producer
was like you know what it's a short week
I'm just taking it let's say that we
won't give it let's say it's like
Rebecca or something and she's just like
you know what I have other things to do
today and so you got no Colton flying
the ship and you're like that mean
Colton's great but where's Rebecca
let's say that you were looking for
better employees well you would be
looking to zip recruiter right now zip
recruit com slash daily wire you need to
check it out so that you only hire the
best candidates zip Roker sends your job
to over 100 of the web's leading job
boards but they do not stop there with
their powerful matching technology zip
recruiter scans thousands of resumes to
find people with the right experience
and then invites them to apply to your
job as applications come in zip
recruiter analyzes each one spotlights
the top candidates so you never miss a
great match zip recruiter is so
effective that four out of five
employers who post on zip recruiter get
a quality candidate through the site
within the very first day right now my
listeners can try zip recruiter for free
at this exclusive web address zip
recruiter comm slash daily wire zip
recruiter comm slash daily wire again
that is zip recruiter comm slash Dai ly
WI re daily wire zipper career is indeed
the smartest way to hire which is why we
use it right here and are constantly
upgrading our staff
it's not a threat to brand new year it's
not a warning it's mostly just a note of
caution okay so we'll get to more of
that in just one second well probably
less of that in just one second but
first president Trump has now responded
to the situation over in Iraq he says
listen the same to Benghazi so the media
immediately starts saying well this is
Trump's Benghazi what's ironic about
this is that the same media declared the
Benghazi was not a problem in the first
place I think I'm saying the Obama
administration handled it brilliantly
well Barack Obama was off partying and
people were dying at the Benghazi
embassy in Libya in 2012 and Hillary
Clinton was lying that she had that she
that this was completely unexpected and
was a protest that went awry in response
to a YouTube video when it was in fact a
terror assault and that her State
Department had turned down security
requests right then the media kept
saying there was no scandal in Benghazi
like none at all there was no cover-up
there was no scandal
it wasn't Susan Rice and the Obama
administration repeatedly the lines the
American people which they did well now
he got MSNBC's joy read he says this is
Trump's Benghazi well but I thought that
Obama has been Goss he wasn't really a
big deal and we had journalists
literally making fun of quote unquote
Benghazi conspiracy theories anyway joy
retweeted out as Trump's Benghazi
unfolds in Iraq okay what okay well I'm
glad to see that you guys came around on
Benghazi was a bad thing so that's
exciting President Trump came out he
said guys this ain't gonna be a Benghazi
because guess what I'm not Obama
- a fantastic job that were there
instantaneously as soon as we heard I
use the word immediately they came
immediately and it's a great shape as
you know this will not be a Benghazi but
Ghazi should never have happened this
will never ever be a Benghazi but we
have some of our greatest warriors there
they got in there very quickly hey peace
through strength and president Trump
embodying it here he's apparently
thinking about deploying 4,000 troops to
the Middle East in order to protect
America's assets abroad this is in fact
the right move a precipitous withdrawal
would drive terrorism it would drive the
rise of our enemies again you will hear
calls on the isolationist right for
exactly that sort of withdrawal
suggesting that now would be a great
time to get out well again that is a
that is a short-term view see the nice
thing about being an isolationist is the
counterfactual is always very useful to
you because the fact is most presidents
are not willing to let America's assets
wither on the vine they're not willing
to let America's enemies run roughshod
over swaths of the globe and then
strengthen themselves so it's easy to
point to costs that have already
occurred and say those costs didn't have
to occur but the counterfactual which is
ok what if America just withdrew and all
of these countries got stronger and then
started launching terror attacks and
started launching economic attacks
because that doesn't occur because of
actions like president Trump's well then
that leaves the isolationist with the
argument that the cost that actually
were incurred were bad the
counterfactual is always a lot easier
than the actual real time cost of things
that are being done right now according
to Fox News the US Army's 82nd Airborne
Division's Alert Brigade has been issued
orders to deploy rapidly to Kuwait amid
the unrest in Baghdad three US defense
officials told Fox News on Tuesday at
least 750 paratroopers are set to deploy
to the region immediately according to
defense secretary mark Esper the alert
brigade of roughly 4000 paratroopers
known as the division ready brigade has
been told to prepare for possible
deployment in the days ahead after
hundreds of Iranian backed militiamen
tried to storm the US Embassy in Baghdad
on Tuesday we actually have video of the
US helicopters
arriving the attack helicopters arriving
in Baghdad suffice it to say who's
shortly thereafter that the Iranian
militia said guys I think maybe you
should pull back yeah no kidding
you should pull back because it turns
out that America our firepower is pretty
extraordinary
and that is an American helicopter
arriving and saying hey guys we're here
just want to let you know Mike Pompeo
the Secretary of State he says we're not
backing down we're not going to give in
to terrorists demands any plans to
evacuate the embassy in Baghdad sir
none okay any plans to pull some of the
five thousand US troops in Iraq out none
we put real pressure on the Islamic
Republic around we will continue to do
so and you saw the president say today
we will continue to hold the Islamic
Republic of Iran accountable wherever we
find their Millian activity and we'll
make sure we have the resources to do so
okay now if you're the Iranians all you
want to do is maintain the pressure long
enough that a Democrat is elected at
which point the United States presumably
would go back to trying to bribe the
Iranians into what piece into decency
that is the thing that's not going to
happen by the way there are protests
against the Iranian influence on the
Iraqi government they're just not being
covered by the media that's another
point that Mike Pompeo was making
meanwhile mark Casper the Secretary of
Defense says that Iran or his proxy
forces may be planning further strikes
on American interests in the Middle East
and the u.s. is prepared to take
pre-emptive military action if it gets
sufficient warning according to s / he
said the game has changed we're prepared
to do what is necessary to defend our
personnel and our interests and our
partners in the region now listen no one
wants a full-scale war with Iranians but
you know who doesn't want a full-scale
war the most the Iranians because if
there's a full-scale where the first
people die or the mullahs and this thing
goes to full-scale war the first people
who have their heads come right off
their bodies are the mullahs in Iran and
they know it so what they're doing right
now is they're pushing and they're
pushing and they're pushing and they're
oppressing their own population and
they're launching low-level terror
assaults when they're doing all of this
in the hopes that they will drive
America out of the Middle East in the
same way that the North Vietnamese that
the Vietcong drove the United States had
a Vietnam and that allowed for a spread
of communist tyranny in that region
they're looking for the same thing to
happen here the difference is that
President Trump is president right now
and the chances that he's going to pull
out precipitously are extremely
extremely low as well they should be
there are things the United States can
do beyond economic sanctions by the way
and striking terror bases is one of
those things hitting at Hezbollah is one
of those things and that can be done
with pretty much zero cost from the air
which is one of the reasons you saw
these demonstrators quote-unquote from
the New York Times these demonstrators
descending on the
because America did strike a series of
terrorist encampments and was very
successful the United States does have
an interest in ensuring safety and
security for America and her allies and
her interests in the region it'll be
interesting to see how these arguments
play out because Trump does have this
sort of isolationist streak but he is
also not somebody who's going to run
away from all of us
meanwhile watching the watching the
Obama administration sycophants like Ben
Rhodes come out and talk about how
terrible Trump is is just a reminder how
awful Obama was the fact is Iran has
been emboldened in the region because of
the Obama administration Trump tweeted
out this is not a warning it is a threat
happy new year
well the the bottom line is that what
he's doing is gonna mean a lot more than
what he is saying right deploying those
troops making sure that our assets are
safe and secure over there all of that
makes a lot of sense it is worth noting
that Barack Obama welcomed the leader of
the u.s. embassy attack to the White
House back in 2011 and he was criticized
for it at the time because the person
was seen as an Iranian proxy even then
okay so that is foreign policy crisis
number one that is facing the Trump
administration but it is not the only
foreign policy crisis facing the Trump
administration as we start a new year
meanwhile North Korea says that it has a
new strategic weapon we'll get to that
in just one moment first let's talk
about your sleep quality so I was away
on vacation a little bit during the
during the last few days and let me just
say my sleep quality when I was away
from my helix sleep mattress it was not
it was not great there are a few things
that were disturbing my sleep
number one children number two I never
the mattress that I need I need my helix
sleeve mattress why because helix sleep
is personalized just for you helix leap
has a quiz that takes just two minutes
to complete matches your body type and
sleep preferences to the perfect
mattress for you whether you're a side
sleeper or hot sleeper whether they like
a plush or a firm bed with helix there's
no more confusion and no more
compromising helix sleep is rated the
number one mattress by GQ and Wired
magazine just head on over to helix
sleep comm slash men take their
two-minute sleep quiz they will match
you to a customized mattress that will
give you the best sleep of your life
they have a 10 year warranty you get to
try it out for 100 nights risk-free
they'll even pick it up for you if you
don't love it but that's not going to
happen you're gonna love it I mean it's
made for you why wouldn't you hilux is
offering up to 200 bucks off all
mattress orders just for our listeners
get up to 200 bucks off at helix sleep
calm
Ben it is helix leap dot-com slash Ben
go check them out right now helix League
comm slash bend get up to 200 bucks off
all mattress orders great deal for a
mattress that is going to give you a
heavenly night's sleep
helix sleep calm slash man go check them
out right now okay meanwhile North Korea
is upping the ante as well no president
goes through their first term without
being tested a little bit president
Trump's strategy on North Korea has been
almost precisely the opposite of his
strategy on Iran his strategy on Iran
has been to push the mullahs to box them
in to cut off their economic lifelines
to weaken them from within that's
largely been successful which is why you
are seeing the the Iranian government
lash out in every direction as they
desperately attempt to fend off the the
protests that have been rolling
throughout their country for the last
what six to nine months in North Korea
the United States has taken the opposite
the sort of opposite tack and that has
been to try and woo kim jungeun
personally I've been very critical of
that attack I've thought that it's been
a waste of time North Korea is showing
each and every day that they're not a
trustworthy partner according to Emily
Zanotti writing over its daily wire
North Korea now says it has a new
strategic weapon and kim jeong-hoon
plans to deploy it soon according to the
Associated Press North Korea says it has
a new strategic weapon that will stun
the world with shocking action North
Korean dictator Kim jong-un plans to
deploy the weapon soon as a way of
challenging at the us's nuclear weapons
superiority Kim jong-un appears to be
using this as a bargaining chip
installed trade talks with the Trump
administration this is always the tactic
of the North Koreans which is to
threaten action fire missiles basically
fuss until you get what you want create
a situation and then suggest that it can
be resolved only by America cutting a
check it has not worked to the benefit
of the United States or to the benefit
of people of North Korea for decades at
this point why I would work with Iran is
beyond me the left wants to see the
North Korean model applied to her it's
funny to watch the media on all this
because Trump is taking this really
bifurcated approach to Iran versus North
Korea they won't endorse either strategy
so when Trump takes this very soft tack
with North Korea which at least is
mildly more justified then it would be
with Iran simply because Iran doesn't
have nuclear weapons yet and North Korea
already does which means that
that you have to treat them with a
little bit more care than you would with
regard to Iran but when it comes to
North Korea the media's like I'll look
at this Trump he's sick of Fanta cailli
kissing ass with with North Korea and
then when it comes to Iran where where
President Trump is taking a very harsh
line though why isn't he sick
offensively kissing ass of the moas like
Barack Obama did guys got a pic one
either you treat America's enemies with
harshness and it's peace through
strength and it's you set up barriers
and rules or it's none of the above
you got a pic you can't just randomly
suggest that it's good when Barack Obama
does it but bad one trump does it that's
not the way any of this works the AP
reports that that hoon says he will soon
reveal a new strategic weapon to the
world as it bolsters its nuclear
deterrent in the face of quote unquote
gangster like u.s. pressure the Trump
administration has been trying to
negotiate with North Korea for years
president Trump sees an inked deal with
the rogue communist nation as a
potential hallmark of his term just a
few short years ago Trump did manage to
secure an anti proliferation treaty with
North Korea halting at the time North
Korea's pursuit of nuclear weapons and
developments of ICBMs but North Korea is
not actually abided by any of those
agreements president Trump dismissed the
threat and North Korea said no no we're
getting along great which of course is
not true here's President Trump saying
it I have a very good relationship with
Kim Jong
I know he's sending out certain messages
about Christmas presents that I hope his
Christmas present is a beautiful vaj
that's what I'd like kebabs
as opposed to something else I don't
know look he likes me I like him we get
along he's representing his country I'm
representing my country we have to do
what we have to do mother I just know
okay if Kim jong-un sent Trump Abbas
back what's this Baz ways that Ava's
here
you need another stupid buzz got
thousand bucks with that set is the
policy with regard to North Korea the
smartness no but is there a really great
policy available in North Korea the
answer of course is no I mean at the
very least North Korea doesn't have
regional aspirations mean North North
Korea is at least somewhat main somewhat
contained the same is not true of rum
okay meanwhile over in New York City
attacks on Jews continue apace we saw
over the Christmas vacation over the
Chanukah the winter vacation we saw an
attack during Hanukkah at a at a house
that was next to a shoal in in Brooklyn
it was an attack on a machete attack by
a guy who'd been let out of jail early
he had a criminal history and it injured
five people including the rabbi of this
particular show this was only the latest
in a spate of attacks there have been a
bunch of attacks over the last month
over the last several weeks and I mean
you can see that we have a mash up of a
bunch of videos of the attacks from
closed-circuit TV pretty frightening
stuff you can see that here's a Jew just
being chased down in the middle of the
street and and beaten up you know they
held to the ground and punched you can
see that I mean this sort of stuff is
happening pretty much every day and it's
overtly religious Jews that are being
targeted disproportionately by people
who happen to be minority doesn't mean
that they're doing it because they're
minority but it is worthwhile noting
this is one of the reasons the media is
not covering it there's a Jewish boy
walking down the street a Jewish man
getting walking down the street getting
clocked from behind by by a young person
of color it appears the only reason that
race is relevant in this conversation is
because the media specifically only talk
about anti-semitic attacks when they are
white supremacists the reason they're
not talking about these anti-semitic
attacks is because they are not against
secularized Jews
left-wing values there against religious
Orthodox Jews in New York City and
they're being perpetrated by members of
the intersectional hierarchy that is the
reason why the media refuses to cover
all of this the New York Times admitted
as much back in 2018 when they said that
even though there was a massive spike in
anti-semitic attacks in the city it's
been ongoing for years at this point
they said that they had failed to cover
it because it quote refuses to conform
to an easy narrative with a single
ideological enemy the fact is the media
refused to take the stuff seriously
specifically because of the nature of
the victims religious Jews who do not
hold left-wing values and the nature of
the victimizers disproportionately young
minority males Jake Tapper got this one
right Jake Tapper is on CNN he was
talking with Barry Weiss and Jane Costin
and here is Jake explaining correctly
that the media response definitely would
have been different if white supremacist
had committed this Konica attack this is
kind of a sensitive question but do you
think the reaction by politicians and
the media would be any different if
these recent anti-semitic attacks had
been committed by white supremacists
instead of who they were committed by I
do and the reason for that is because it
took a man walking in with a machete the
size of a broomstick for there to be any
public outrage during the holiday of
Hanukkah yeah that of course is true it
is also true that the Jersey City attack
disappeared from mainstream newspapers
and not only that was covered by
mainstream newspapers as a response to
gentrification with Jews coming in and
offering to buy apartments from black
folks in Jersey City and the fact is the
media only cover anti-semitism when it
is convenient to their narrative but
anti-semitism comes from a wide variety
of sources including disproportionately
in terms of opinion black Americans are
disproportionately anti-semitic compared
to other racial subgroups of Americans
according to the anti-defamation league
again only relevant because what you're
seeing in New York City is
disproportionately these hacks taking
place from members of minority
communities okay that if this were a
white supremacist thing the media would
be covering it because it is
uncomfortable to talk about the fact
that there is disproportionate
anti-semitism among African Americans in
the United States the media simply
refused to cover it Armen Rosen wrote
four tablet magazine back in july 2019
about the Jew hatred New York correctly
noted quote that the victims are most
outwardly identifiable ie religious
rather than second
Jews the perpetrators who have been
recorded on CCTV cameras are
overwhelmingly black and Hispanic the
media therefore does not want to cover
all of this because this cuts directly
against the supposed alliance of
intersectionality in which all minority
groups are allied against the white
superstructure the left just ignores the
wrong type of anti-semitism and so the
same media that will that will derive
great joy from suggesting the president
from the most pro-israel present in the
history of the United States is actually
an anti-semite the same media that will
pretend that president Trump's executive
order for campus designed to protect
Jews in the same way that it protects
blacks on American campuses are actually
anti-semitic well will suggest that it
is perfectly wrong to cover the fact
that Barack Obama sat in Jeremiah
Wright's church for twenty years while
Jeremiah Wright spewed anti-semitism he
did for two decades we know this
Democratic candidates who suggest that
Trump has emboldened anti-semites well
now make pilgrimage they have been doing
this right you've seen this from people
who to judge he made pilgrimage to Al
Sharpton in actual anti-semite who's
involved in the incitement allegedly
involved in the incitement of two
separate anti-semitic riots in New York
City and who now has a show on MSNBC so
yes the identity of the victims matters
and so does the identity of the
victimizers the same commentators will
police Republicans for mentioning George
Soros so if you say George Soros is a
nefarious force in American politics
which by the way he is he does some very
bad things in American politics then
they'll say oh that's anti-semitism a
convention George Soros if by the way
you mentioned anything about right-wing
Jewish donors if you mentioned something
about about Sheldon Adelson then
obviously that's not anti-semitic that's
just you critiquing money in politics
but if you do it about George Soros it's
anti-semitic and then they'll just
excuse open anti-semitism from Rasheeda
Talib and ohan Omar by the way the the
statement that I made about
disproportionate anti-semitism inside
the black community that's supported by
a consistent polling done by the
anti-defamation league every single year
if you're not gonna call out
anti-semitism whenever you see it you're
doing it wrong but the media are not
interested in doing it because for them
it's just a tool it's just in this in
this latest spate Amman systematic
attacks in New York is perfect example
of this I'll get to more of that in just
a second first let's talk about the the
fact that one of the most important
things in the context of marriage
particularly is your sex life I mean
obviously this is
were important but it can be sometimes
awkward to discuss if you've got a
problem with your sex life well if you
got a problem you really ought to go fix
it
if you're dealing with a condition like
a reptile dysfunction or hair loss or
cold sores you should get treatment ASAP
it's not always comfortable or something
you want to do but you should take care
of it
both for you and your partner that's why
our friends at Roman have spent years
building a digital platform that could
connect you with a doctor licensed in
your state all from the comfort of your
home
Roman makes it convenient to get the
treatment you need on your schedule you
just grab your phone or computer you
complete a free online visit and you'll
hear back from a u.s. licensed physician
within 24 hours if the doctor decides
the treatment is right for you
Romans pharmacy can ship your medication
to you with free two-day shipping you
also get free unlimited follow ups with
your doctor anytime you have questions
or you want to adjust your treatment
plan with Roman no commitments you can
cancel anytime so if you are struggling
with
edie or hair loss cold sores other
issues go to get Roman comm /ban for a
free online visit in free two-day
shipping that is get Roman comm slash
been for that free online visit and free
two-day shipping can we can get some
more of the anti semitism in New York
City we'll also get to impeachment and
the 2020 race work Bernie Sanders is
showing some life despite the fact that
he basically been declared dead just a
couple of months ago we'll get to all of
that in just one second first you need
to go over to daily wire.com and
subscribe right now right now you need
to go do it
gang 2020 is gonna be a crazy news
filled year with the upcoming election
impeachment attempts democratic cage
matches debates and so much more we know
that you need to know everything that is
going on the best way to stay informed
on all things 2020 is to become a daily
wire member and get comprehensive news
and opinion from us on demand so we are
giving you 20% off all memberships until
January 6th yep 20% off all memberships
when you use promo code DW 2020 members
get our articles add free access to all
of our live broadcasts and show library
the full three hours of the Ben Shapiro
show select bonus content access to the
mailbag and more plus our new all access
to your gets you into live online Q&A
discussions with me which is the best
also other people like Andrew Clavin
Matt Walsh Michael Knowles Jeremy Boren
plus our sites writers and special
guests with all the crazy complicated
election updates
let us answer your questions again that
is a promo code DW 2024 20% off until
Monday January 6th June today stay
informed on all things 2020 with promo
DW 2024 20% off until Monday
you
okay so the the issue of anti-semitism
again being treated as a as a political
football by the left because this is
what the political left enjoys doing
apparently CNN's Sam Vine a grad blamed
President Trump for the situation in New
York to try to excuse Andrew Cuomo the
governor of New York and Bill de Blasio
the mayor of New York and she blamed
President Trump in the process for the
fact that Bill de Blasio who claimed
that there was no anti-semantic problem
like five weeks ago after that Jersey
City attacked he suggested well male
anti-semitism has reached the doorstep
of New York City no it's been there for
a very long time you just don't care
about it because it's coming in a form
that you wish not to recognize Andrew
Cuomo who came out and said well this is
just it has to do with the general tone
and tenor of politics in our country
trying to blame Trump for something
happening in his own state here's CNN's
him find a grad doing the same thing we
have not seen the US government address
the lessons of countering extremism in
really a strategic way and I do not
understand why President Trump has the
authority and the ability to call
together a whole-of-government approach
on this issue and has failed to do so do
so while concurrently unfortunately
really propagating some anti-semitic
narratives so you see so you see somehow
the I guess the people who are beating
up Jews in Williamsburg are actually
Trump supporters shocker who didn't see
that one coming I'll be honest with you
really did not see that coming probably
the pair of goons who flashed a knife
according to the New York Post is they
yelled hey Jew boy at a Brooklyn teen
over the weekend spewing that hate at a
17 year old victim walking on Avenue o
near 8th Street apparently that was
probably that was probably a bunch of
white supremacists by the way not a
single incident in New York City has
been linked to white supremacy but
obviously this has to do with President
Trump demonstrating once again that the
West doesn't care about anti-semitism
depending on the source Jay Michaelson
wrote a piece over at The Daily Beast
where he tried to explain that left-wing
anti-semitism is basically fine because
the reality is that left-wing
anti-semitism is rooted in reality where
right-wing white supremacist
anti-semitism is rooted in mere
conspiracy theorizing it really this is
this is what this idiot wrote it's
unbelievable he says this combination of
baseless hatred he's talking about the
conspiracy theorizing in the in the
Jersey City community among some people
about Jews selling organs and
gentrification he says
this combination of baseless hatred and
socio-economic grievance stands in stark
contrast to the word wordy theoretical
manifestos of white supremacist
anti-semitism and while some attackers
cite conspiracy theories similar to the
ones on the nationalist right such as
the black Hebrew Israelite doctrines
noted above the social context and
relationships to power our utter ly
different while conspiracy mongering
exists on the left hand the right there
is no left-wing where african-american
equivalent of President Trump who is
freely treated traded in anti-semitic
stereotypes sometimes in a joking way
after all the notorious anti-semite
Louis Farrakhan may be the leader of the
Nation of Islam but Trump is the leader
of the free world and then he just
blames Trump for all of this literally
the Democratic Party this year or last
year rather excuse the anti-semitism of
rashida to leave in ohan Omar and made
them part of the squad and elevated them
literally last year
Peabody judge made pilgrimage tile
Sharpton but don't worry guys there's no
anti-semitic problem inside the
Democratic Party by the way speaking of
things that New York City could do to
stop all of us how about you get rid of
your idiotic bail policy they've now
pushed bail reform in New York City and
it turns out that when you don't hold
criminals on bail they go commit crimes
who could have predicted such a thing
who except for every functional sentient
human being with a prefrontal cortex
according to the New York Post suspects
arrested in last week's spree of eight
anti-semitic attacks are quickly being
released right back into the
neighborhood's they terrorize thanks to
bail reform legislation which doesn't
even take effect until January first
most recent case of revolving-door
justice came Saturday morning with the
release with no bail of a woman charged
with punching and cursing at three
Orthodox women ages 20 to 26 and 31 in
Crown Heights Brooklyn at dawn the day
before the accused assailant Tiffany
Harris was hauled in handcuffs before a
Brooklyn judge on 21 menacing harassment
and attempted assault charges
a few Jews Harris allegedly shouted
during the attack yes I was there Harris
later admitted to the cops yes I slapped
them I cursed them out I said f you Jews
as she stood before a judge in Brooklyn
Criminal Court with a hood to a navy
blue jacket over her head Harris was in
familiar territory she still has an open
harassment and assault case on the
Brooklyn docket from November last month
she was sentenced to no jail time for
felony criminal mischief in Manhattan
she's completely failed to show up for
court appearances but Brooklyn
prosecutors didn't even bother
requesting bail on Saturday given that
the reform
approved in April technically doesn't
take effect until January 1st the
DeBlasio administration has made it
clear we all need to get in compliance
with bail reform now so you can't even
hold these people on bail who are
committing crimes Harris broke into a
grin when approached by a reporter why
do you want to know goodbye she said
absolute insanity absolute insanity but
welcome to left-wing governance which is
ruining major American cities across the
country meanwhile there is a there was
another act of violence that took the
headlines for five seconds because once
again it did not fit the media's
narrative and that was this attack at a
Texas church that happened over the
holidays apparently according to The
Wall Street Journal a streaming video of
the Sunday church service in Texas at
which a parishioner gunned down a
shooter is rallying those who support
making it easier for private citizens to
bear arms gun rights advocates have long
argued that if more citizens have guns
they can defend themselves and others in
the events of a shooting on Sunday
morning is that last Sunday a gunman
opened fire at West freeway Church of
Christ in white settlements near Fort
Worth he killed two people before a
parishioner who's part of a volunteer
security force fatally shot him and you
can actually see this happened in the
video you can see the shooter who
arrives on scene start shooting at
people and a bunch of people in the
crowd pull out guns and a security
officer puts down the the shooter and
shoots the shooter hey it was amazing
there are people on the Left who are
tweeting yeah but the real threat was
that there were people in the audience
who didn't really know what to do with
their guns and were unlicensed with
their guns that was the real threat
obviously yeah this is let's just say
this if that Hanukkah party that was
attacked by a guy with a machete
if there'd been anyone and anyone there
with a gun it wouldn't be five people
injured it would be one terrorists dead
that's what have been happening and what
would have been happening there everyone
who wishes to protect themselves and
their communities should become a
responsible gun owner they should know
how to use they should coordinate with
the authorities they should they should
do all appropriate things to defend
themselves by the way speaking of idiocy
again the u.s. criminal justice system
is broken but not in terms of keeping
people in jail too long all the time
sometimes it's broken in terms of this
revolving door that we have with crime
it turns out that the man who fatally
shot two people at the white settlement
Church before being killed by church
security was had a long criminal history
and was described by his ex-wife is
battling a
and not nice to anyone the shooter was
identified on Monday morning by two law
enforcement sources familiar with the
investigation NBC 5 has learned that his
criminal past included charges of
assault theft arson and possession of an
illegal weapon in Texas Oklahoma and New
Jersey
what a delight I mean it's just it's a
it's unbelievable you set up a revolving
door for criminals and then you're
shocked when it turns out that the
criminals go and do terrible things
it meanwhile with all of this happening
with all this turmoil internationally
and domestically the Democrats are
focused laser-like on impeachment they
continue to move forward with
impeachment although Nancy Pelosi still
has not set forth a timeline as to when
she will convey the impeachment charges
to the Senate remember that impeachment
was passed in the house but she has not
actually passed that on to the Senate
there's an interesting legal debate
going on right now of whether Mitch
McConnell actually needs that there's
nothing in the Constitution that
suggests that Nancy Pelosi number one is
compelled to hand over the impeachment
charges to McConnell but there's nothing
also that says that McConnell can't hold
a separate trial on the basis of those
impeachment charges their public after
all and then just to quit so there's a
debate over whether McConnell should do
that right now or whether he should just
point at Pelosi and say the reason she's
holding this back is because she knows
what's going to happen next
meanwhile Rudy Giuliani continues to
militate in favor of his own testimony
which is presumably the worst idea that
ever happened there's at mar-a-lago over
the weekend suggesting that he would
love to testify which would be the worst
possible idea because Rudy Giuliani is
is not his own best witness here's Rudy
so there is explaining that he would
love to testify love to testify the
Republicans would be fools do that
meanwhile everybody in the country is
already broken down into lines on this
one okay everybody knows where they
stand and the reason they know where
they stand is because this is not about
what Trump did or did not do with
Ukraine it is a generalized referendum
on Trump guess what we get to have a
generalized referendum on Trump in just
about 11 months here it is fast
approaching the election most Americans
in the end want this to be decided by
the American people they do not want
this to be decided by Nancy Pelosi and
Cru they do not think that whatever are
the allegations rise to the level of
getting rid of a sitting president the
only people who are in favor of all of
this are people like Linda Ronstadt who
came out on CNN and explained to
Anderson Cooper who is busy getting
brutally drunk on New Year's Eve I mean
just going wild on New Year's Eve with
Anderson it confuses me as to why CNN
thinks that this is good broadcasting or
a good idea you're a news network and
you have your anchors making absolute
mockeries of themselves on national TV
do they think that it makes them seem
fun or does it make it seem like they
might be out of touch with their actual
jobs you you always you call yourself
the most trusted name in news and get
James Earl Jones to do the voice-over
and then you got Anderson Cooper and Don
Lemon getting blackout drunk on national
TV anyway here's Linda Ronstadt over the
weekend explaining that President Trump
is the new Hitler Hitler rose to power
with a lot of chances to stop him and
they didn't speak out and the industrial
complex thought that they could control
and once they got him in office and of
course he was not controllable and by
the time he got established he put his
own people in place and is you know
stacked the courts and did what he had
to do to consolidate his power if you
read the history will be surprised it's
exactly the same yet you can find a
common enemy for everybody to hate when
I was sure that Trump was going to get
elected the day he announced and I said
he's gonna it's gonna be like Hitler and
the Mexicans in the new Jews and sure
enough that's what he delivered you know
the Mexicans are the new Jews really
like a huge percentage of the American
population is Hispanic nobody's being
rounded up and put in boxcars
this is so insulting and so stupid if
you feel like this is who Trump is of
course you're pushing for impeachment
despite the fact that you don't actually
have the evidence for this meanwhile the
Democrats are basically hoping that they
can peel off a couple of Republican
senators to cut against McConnell and
and drive for a quote-unquote more
even-handed impeachment effort
impeachment
trial in the Senate it's not really
going to happen Susan Collins did say
that she was open to having witnesses at
trial here was Susan Collins from Maine
I am open to witness since I think it's
premature to decide who should be called
until we see the evidence that is
presented and get the answers to the
questions that we Senators can submit
through the Chief Justice to both sides
what I don't understand is why the house
having issued subpoenas to secretary
Pompeo for example did not seek to
enforce those subpoenas in court and
instead rush to get the articles of
impeachment passed before Christmas and
yet have not transmitted them to us in
the Senate okay so people are reading
this as Susan Collins somehow cutting
against McConnell you listen that whole
quote not really she's basically saying
yeah sure I'd like to see a trial but
the house didn't do its job so this is
going nowhere everybody knows it's going
nowhere it's all a sham we can move on
with our lives
by early February this thing will be
over and we'll be in primary season full
swing by the way Bernie Sanders raised a
boatload of money that dude is on the
move
watch out Democrats you may nominate an
actual open octogenarian socialist okay
time for a quick thing I like and then a
thing that I hate so things that I like
today okay this is anything so quick
because as you all know I'm a
large-scale Star Wars fan I'm a big Star
Wars geek my kids are now super into
Star Wars like we got them nothing but
Star Wars gifts for Hanukkah and they
could not be happier I honestly I wish
that the world were not such a terrible
place particularly in social media so I
could post videos of my kids because it
is adorable I have the best video of my
three-year-old son who's very into
Empire Strikes Back I know maybe a
little old for him but he gets it he
likes it and and there are many videos
of me turning to him now and saying no I
am your father and him saying that's not
true that's impossible and me saying
search your feelings you know it to be
true and him going No
my kids are very into it okay so I
finally got a chance a couple nights ago
to see rise of Skywalker we were out of
the country for a bit of a vacation and
and when he got back
like first move my wife and I go to sea
rise of Skywalker now if you've been
familiar with
show at all you know I've been
incredibly critical of the new trilogy I
don't like the new trilogy I think it
was unnecessary I think they were fools
I think they tried to split the baby so
there were two things they could have
done originally I have to preface my
take on rise of Skywalker with the other
two movies because it doesn't work as a
standalone film nor is it really meant
to this film rise of Skywalker was
designed specifically to retcon meaning
to go back in time and change the fact
that force awakens and last Jedi ever
happened it basically revises the entire
story in a much more satisfying way okay
so here was my original take on this new
trilogy there are two ways that Disney
could have gone Disney number one could
have recast the entire original Return
of the Jedi they could have recast
somebody as Luke recast somebody as lay
out recast somebody as han which by the
way they did they recast somebody is Han
right they did Solo they could have
recast the entire cast and then they
could have just picked up a Return of
the Jedi left off with the Admiral
Thrawn series which read any of the Star
Wars books yes I have
if you then that's actually a really
good storyline and it could have just
picked up where they left off and moved
on into the future that way and it would
gotten all of their new adventures
alternatively they could have landed the
Star Wars universe in like a different
place and they're actually doing this on
his knee plus with the Mandalorian which
is kind of great right the Mandalorian
is is really fun Jon Favreau directed it
they could have gone back and they could
have used some of these characters and
put them somewhere else in the Star Wars
universe
so this is so Disney actually has done
this with a couple of their other series
right Star Wars Clone Wars they did this
with and also Star Wars rebels and some
of that stuff is really pretty fantastic
yeah they could have done any of those
things instead what they chose to do was
split the baby will introduce two new
characters but we'll live off the
uninstall jar for the first film's you
can't do that and the reason you can't
do that is because if you're in a stall
check for the first film's you don't
want to see bad things happen to your
favorite childhood characters no one
what spoiler alert
no one wants to see Han Solo die at the
hands of his son like a loser divorced
dad after leaving Leia alone for 20
years and flying around the galaxy
smoking pot with Chewie and the
Millennium Falcon no one wants to see
that and that's what happens in force
awakens no one wants to see Luke who is
this hero who goes from being a whiny
teenager to being this mature Jedi who
is able to control himself to save his
father nobody wants to see Luke become a
misanthrope who milks aliens on a
foreign planet while whining about his
life and disparaging the Jedi tradition
no one wants to see that so the new
series basically took all of your
favorite characters your favorite old
characters and proceeded to ruin them
except for Leia
because kathleen kennedy has this
feminist streak where the only
characters were allowed to be competent
or good are apparently the female
characters okay so that that was the
critique of this trilogy they basically
took all of my favorite characters of my
childhood and they wrecked them so they
could promote a bunch of characters who
sucked okay ray was a terrible character
because he didn't know not only you
didn't know where she came from but she
was amazing at everything right off the
bat right this was the biggest critique
of the first part of this trilogy the
biggest critique was that Ray who had
not trained in the force for half a
second was suddenly unbelievably good at
it and been so low right kylo Ren who is
Leia's Leia's kid with Han who's been
training with the force since childhood
can be overtaken in a lightsaber battle
by somebody who picked up a lightsaber
half a second ago okay that's not a
thing
it's stupid and everybody who watched
the series knew it was stupid meanwhile
he had Poe who is utterly incompetent
they tried to create kind of a new Han
Solo character the difference is that
Han Solo in Empire Strikes Back the
entire story of Empire Strikes Back is
Han Solo demonstrating that he's wildly
competent and a lot of things the entire
Poe Dameron stories the dude is wildly
incompetent until he suddenly promoted
to the head of the Rebel Alliance Finn
has no story arc at all his entire story
arc is that he was a stormtrooper end of
story arc nothing happens to him for the
next three movies so all of the new
characters are completely boring random
they should have killed Finn in last
Jedi when he makes that heroic run they
should have killed them off they
probably should have killed Poe in last
Jedi they should have had him pull the
the Admiral whole go maneuver instead
they bring in a laura dern to wear weird
hair into a Lightspeed trick that by the
way if anybody could have figured that
one out they could have blown up the
Death Star that way like in Star Wars
new hope as well as Return of the Jedi
okay so all of this is prefaced to say I
hated force awakens and I hated last
Jedi rise of Skywalker is an attempt to
buy all of that back and understanding
that this trilogy never should have
happened and understanding all the flaws
of force awakens and and last Jedi now
you understand why I liked rise of
Skywalker because they attempt to
correct as many of these problems as
they can while apologizing for the
series of resisting which is basically
what this was so
all of the stuff with Finn and Poe no
one cares about all that stuff was dumb
no one cares about it it's a waste of
time you have to do it it's like the
worst of JJ Abrams like the feel it's
not a spoiler to say the film opens with
the Millennium Falcon
Lightspeed jumping which just turns it
into like a silly prop like they it's
it's ridiculous it's ridiculous the
entire Empire Strikes Back which is the
best Star Wars film unquestionably this
is fact this is known ok Empire Strikes
Back is all about basically maybe four
topics one is the Millennium Falcon it's
the entire thing in Empire Strikes Back
is that the Millennium Falcon's
hyperdrive is broken okay that is the
central plot device in this movie in in
the new movie and rise of Skywalker the
Millennium Falcon is fully on fire and
they fix it inside of five seconds flat
all of it named Al also Empire Strikes
Back is about Luke growing and realizing
that he is insufficient okay so that
that's the other topic and also it's
about Han Solo being wildly competent so
Po and and Finn they're wildly
incompetent the Millennium Falcon is
made into a prop like all that stuff is
sort of the worst of JJ Abrams the stuff
that's really good okay the stuff that's
really good is actually quite good the
stuff that's good is that they buy back
Han Solo's death they give him sort of a
new exit scene where he's not being
killed by his son where they cheat he
can't be a force ghost cuz headon have
the force but he basically is a force
ghost he comes back all these are
spoilers okay spoilers you've been
warned 1000 times you don't want to hear
about he haven't seen the movie yet
don't listen
hey so Han Solo comes back and he talks
with kylo and he basically was kylo back
to the light side of the force you find
out that Leia
who uses the Force in new and bizarre
ways in last Jedi better never explain
like she literally pulls herself back
into a ship after being blasted out into
space you know like where that hell did
that come from Luke hasn't even done
that you're told in in this movie that
Leia was trained as a Jedi by Luke which
makes sense right in the books she
actually is and the book she actually is
trained as a Jedi by Luke and that she
decided not to become a Jedi at the last
minute because she first saw using the
force that if she became a Jedi
then her lightsaber would be used to
kill Ben okay so that all makes sense
so they retcon that and then the biggest
retcon of all the one that actually
matters and that answers why rey is cool
ready to answer is the biggest question
why is rey even a thing and the answer
is because she's Palpatine's
granddaughter which is fantastic okay
that's a great review
that's great because the most underrated
force ability person in the Star Wars
series cuz everyone's focused on Anakin
Skywalker on Vader on Luke on Leia on
Yoda on obi-wan nobody's focused on the
fact that Palpatine is an unbelievable
badass with the force right Palpatine is
so strong in the force that he basically
defeats Yoda he is able to conceal his
identity as the emperor for three movies
he's able to turn anakin to the dark
side like Palpatine is an utter badass
and so they bring Palpatine back from
the dead which they sort of had to do
Palpatine is a great character they they
bring in all the old musical cues they
bring in all of the old stuff which is
the stuff that I like so if you're a
nostalgic person right if you're pissed
at this series because you feel like a
Bruin your childhood then this this
movie was an attempt to restore that it
was an attempt to make Han cool again
fair fairly successful it was an attempt
to make Leia cool again successful
there's an attempt to make Luke cool
there's a great scene where Luke does
even though he's dead right Luke does
this thing that Yoda does while he's
alive in Empire remember an empire
there's this call there's this scene
where Yoda raises the the x-wing from
the swamp because Luke fails to do so
here Luke is able to do that as a force
goes to handover the x-wing to wreck
that's great
the callback scene where they find the
old Death Star from Return of the Jedi
and Rey has to confront herself which is
another callback to Empire and then when
they're playing the old musical cues and
all that stuff is great what they do
with kylo Ren bringing him back to the
light side is pretty great JJ Abrams
does a great job in setting up a good
reveal so for several movies you've been
seeing basically kylo and Rey for
skyping one another maybe they can talk
over the long distances in this movie
they can actually sword fight sort of
telepathically but it has real-world
ramifications one is in one place one is
in the other place and they're having
these lightsaber battles but it actually
has physical ramifications in the places
where they're having the lightsaber
battles and so that ends with a really
fantastic reveal and all that stuff is
great so everything with kylo everything
with Rey everything with Palpatine is
great everything with Leia and Han is
really good like all that stuff is good
Finn and Poe continue to be disposable
all the other French characters end up
being disposable there is this lesbian
moment that's been much talked about
because at the very end of the movie
they show a lesbian couple kissing and
it's obviously Disney trying to shoehorn
in the okay glad we know you're there
it's very silly and it's very it's sort
of like that moment
at the end of the Avengers infinity war
where all the females land in one part
of the battlefield you know like okay
really was that like come on yeah that's
it that's sort of the same thing here
none of the couples are kissing except
this one lesbian couple alright I get it
is name I get you're fine you fulfilled
your PC quota for the day whatever man
but it's it's pretty shoehorned in it's
not a big deal it's just silly
okay that but overall the critics are
savaging this film all it tells you
about critics all you need to know is
they gave the last Jedi like ninety two
percent on Rotten Tomatoes and they gave
this one like fifty three percent they
didn't understand Star Wars
he didn't understand it this movie
understands better how the force works
this movie understands better how the
weapons work this movie understands
better the dynamics between the light
and the dark side it understands
Palpatine I've heard a lot of objections
that this film basically makes the
Skywalker Vader interaction completely
irrelevant but that's true the minute
that Palpatine lives right I mean the
and by the way that's true the minute
that the Rebel Alliance fails once the
Republic falls again to the first-order
then that whole thing became irrelevant
the new trilogy made that irrelevant
which is why they should have fast
forwarded and taken it to some other
part of the universe but once you're in
the trilogy this was the best way to end
it here's a little bit the trailer if
you haven't already seen it are you
doing there in Threepio taking one last
look sir
but my friends
frontin fear is the destiny of a Jedi
your destiny
[Music]
okay so this is it's sort of like Return
of the Jedi this one specifically
because the part that you care about is
all the stuff with the Emperor and all
the stuff on on Endor doesn't matter as
much that's pretty much this movie
everything between ray and kylo and the
Emperor and all the old characters is
great and everything else is disposable
but good for JJ Abrams for at least
trying to go back and Unruh in
everything that he ruined the force
awakens and there Ryan Johnson then
proceeded to wreck in last Jedi okay I
know I went on a long time about Star
Wars but guess what tough it's a new
year it's my show I get to say what I
want so you know what we're gonna start
the new year on an upbeat note we're not
gonna do things I hate cuz I just took
forever talking about Star Wars but
suffice to say he liked the old Star
Wars you should totally you should
totally see this one it is definitely
better than the last two in the series
and everybody who's ripping on it didn't
understand why the last few sucked
alrighty we'll be back here a little bit
later to know two additional hours of
content including all of your election
updates Bernie Sanders raising tons of
money where we are in the polls Joe
Biden stepping in it again we'll get to
all that two hours later today it's why
should subscribe you get 20% off today
when you go to daily we're calm slash
subscribe so go make that happen
otherwise we'll see you here tomorrow
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Rebecca Dodd poets directed by Mike
joiner executive producer Jeremy boring
senior producer Jonathan hey supervising
producers Mathis Glover and Robert
Stirling technical producer Austin
Stephens associate producer Colton Haas
assistant director pavel white house key
edited by adam sai events audio is mixed
by Mike Romina
hair and makeup is my jl l vera
production assistant nick Sheehan the
Ben Shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 19
iran-backed terrorists attacked the US
Embassy in Baghdad on New Year's Eve but
decisive leadership dispelled the
violence we will examine why Baghdad
didn't turn into Benghazi and what it
means as we look forward to the coming
decade check it out on the Michael Nolt
show
[Music]